no man's sky is getting even better and
battlefield 2042 is hoping to start a
redemption arc
no man's sky developer hello games has
announced the next update for the game
and it's called outlaws launching on
april 14th outlaws will focus on the
game's underworld and also includes a
number of significant upgrades
throughout no man's sky for the new
underworld exploration you'll be able to
visit outlaw space stations and star
systems that have been overtaken by
criminal elements which creates an
opportunity for you to earn extra
credits a new series of pirate missions
will open up black market technology
that you can purchase valuable goods
that are illegal elsewhere in the galaxy
can be acquired and you can even grab a
forged passport that will allow you to
slip past the sentinels with your
smuggled cargo all players not just
smugglers will benefit from the addition
of specialist cargo inventories to all
starships you'll even be able to recruit
and upgrade your own wingmen now as well
allowing you to collect your ideal set
of ships and pilots each pilot comes
with their own abilities and can be
upgraded over time to improve their
combat skills and speaking of combat
space combat has also been overhauled
significantly and will now have a
decidedly faster feel to its design
handling has been improved weapons have
new visual effects and enemy starships
now have shields and you won't be safe
on the planet's atmosphere either as
ship-to-ship combat can now occur there
too i secretly aspire to be really good
at no man's sky like an expert at no
man's sky but all these new releases
just keep pulling me away
i guess it's time to redownload it
anyway so i'm ready for the release
tomorrow and in other update news sony
has released new firmware for the
playstation 5 and unsurprisingly it
doesn't do much other than provide a
standard system performance update still
no variable refresh rate support just
yet the previous ps5 firmware update was
more substantial as it added several new
features and tweaked the user interface
personally i'm just still waiting on the
ability to hold the playstation button
and access the power menu alright let's
stick with the update talk because the
next big patch for battlefield 2042 is
coming next week the update has 400 plus
changes including bug fixes and quality
of life improvements among other things
for starters specialists rao and pake
will see their traits updated but dice's
kevin johnson didn't say how sundance
meanwhile will see fixes to their
grenade belt to allow for better
anti-armor grenade target acquisition
within their immediate vicinity update
4.0 will also change ribbons so that
they're easier to unlock across all
modes what's more xp for support actions
and team play will be balanced with the
aim of making sure quote teamwork
remains king vehicles are also getting
some attention too the bolt vehicle for
example will see targeted tweaks to
ensure the balance between infantry and
vehicles still has some bite there are
also fixes in store for aiming down
sights while jumping out of a vehicle
and reviving others near obstacles the
4.0 update also makes changes to
attachments with the aim of quote
ensuring they feel unique and have an
impact on your loadout choice and gun
play this is only a small preview of
what's to come in battlefield 2042's 4.0
update the full patch notes are coming
early next week ahead of the patch's
release an official release date for the
patch hasn't been revealed just yet
however and before we end let's take a
small moment of silence for the witcher
3's ps5 and xbox series xns editions as
it was delayed
indefinitely today
thank you
i'll see you tomorrow